hey youtubers is Charlie so I had a
chance to go to the night before our
stars for TIFIA so this is gonna be my
review the movie if you've never heard
of it before it's a young adult drama
based on a novel by one half of the
vlogbrothers John Green I assure you it
is an endurance test in trying to not
cry which is part of the reason why I
was so excited to go say with a big
group of people that were such a big
fans of the book because a lot of you
probably haven't seen it yet I'm gonna
do my non-spoilery review first as well
as talk about the night before our stars
event and then I'll give a spoiler
warning and do my top 5 moments and a
breakdown of all the differences between
the movie and the book for any of you
who are book readers if you're finding
me for the first time I'm just doing big
summer movie reviews each week be sure
to subscribe to get everything
the next thing that's coming is How to
Train Your Dragon 2 and transformers but
feel free to leave me any suggestions
for big movies that you want me to do so
first the night before stars was just a
special preview screening event with a
Q&A with the cast and crew it was Shane
Lee Woodley Ansel Elgort NAT Wolff and
John Green and a bunch other people from
the movie they just answered questions
after the movie was over if you're a
fellow nerdfighter you will be pleased
to know that they showed John Green's
cameo in the movie it got cut for time
so you won't see it when you go see the
movie in theaters he claimed that he was
really happy that it was cut out of the
film but all of nerdfighteria will
really enjoy it whenever the DVD comes
out the place where I went to see the
movie was understandably full of you
know mostly teenage women and Families
it was a lot like the time I went to see
the last Twilight movie in the theaters
but it was very different experience
because at the Twilight movie almost
everyone was just laughing at the movie
and obviously it tiffy owes everyone was
pretty much crying their eyes out there
were a lot of funny moments in the movie
but obviously it's the crying that
everyone's talking about it's a really
good movie to see if you're one not
afraid to cry and to want a really deep
emotional experience that you might not
get it a big effects driven action movie
and three I guess you could say it's
always fun to watch a movie about a book
that you really really love especially
just to watch it unfold in front of your
eyes I will caution you if you are a
huge fan of the book your eyes will
either burn in their sockets from all
the excitement or just melt from all the
tears one of my favorite things about
the movie was that it's totally upfront
about what it is a young adult cancer
drama intended to yank on your
heartstrings and ask the question you
know what happens to the people you
leave behind but it doesn't in a very
authentic way
I did end up having to squish down a lot
of old feelings that the movie reminded
me of whenever I was you know 16 to 18 I
guess if you really wanted to explain
this story to someone in an even simpler
way you could just say pain demands to
be felt I am pretty good at keeping the
feels pushed down but if you ever wanted
to be part of a big group of people all
feeling the same thing at the same time
then this will be the best movie that
you go see all summer for all the book
readers out there I'll talk about more
specific things that the movie change
during spoilers in case you want to wait
till you see it but even if you don't
consider yourself part of nerdfighteria
or a nerdfighter dftba and go see this
movie this will go down is the
highest-grossing movie
originated by a youtuber and the
community of nerdfighters is the big
reason why everyone knows about it I
won't make any comparisons just because
it wasn't like any other movie I've seen
in the last year and that's a very very
good thing so here's where I'm gonna get
into spoilers and talk about my top 5
moments as well as things that the movie
change from the book so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet but here we go
number 5 Augustus passionately defends
price of Don this really reminded me of
every time I tried to convince a
girlfriend over the years to watch Star
Wars or Lord of the Rings I was also a
huge fan of the dragon lands books in
middle school which is kind of like a
Dungeons and Dragons series of novels I
was never quite as articulate as
Augustus he really knows how to sell a
book to someone number four Willem Dafoe
as Van Houten he was awful and funny at
the same time which was totally on
purpose the character is so terrible all
you can do is laugh at him especially
whenever he jumped into Hazel's car at
the funeral be sure to let me know in
the comments whether or not you ever
listened to Swedish hip hop after
reading the book or seeing the movie
remember it's not important what they're
saying it's what they're feeling number
three hazel and Augustus talk while
Isaac smashes stuff I left a lot while
this was going on mostly because
Augustus has this unbroken attention on
hazel in their conversation about
imperial affliction and you see Hazel's
eyes dart back and forth between trophy
smashing and Augustus like she's
surprised both by Isaac going crazy and
the fact that Augustus is totally able
to ignore it
I also admired the scene on a technical
level just because it must have been so
hard for the actors to remember their
lines while all that stuff was going on
it'd be like listening to two different
people at the same time
and having two different conversations
and remembering everything without
messing up number two the birth of the
okay's that whole initial text montage
and the way the movie visually showed
their text was really cool but I feel
like the okay's were one of the most
important parts of the story like that
was the real moment they became bonded
as a couple I thought that was way more
meaningful and emotional than whatever
they actually ended up having sex but
let me know what moment you think they
actually became a real couple and my
number one moment
dinner amongst the stars in Amsterdam I
feel like this was the real climax of
the movie because hazel finally got over
her grenade fears and just let herself
be in love with Augustus who was just
totally on fire seriously Ansel Elgort
was really on fire during this scene the
really intimate way that they filmed the
dinner made it feel like they were just
floating in heaven all night I really
like the way they used the lights on the
tree as a visual metaphor for that I
don't think that Dom pérignon tastes
like stars but in that moment in space
and time it totally felt like it did but
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what was your favorite
moment from the film and as promised
here's a breakdown of all the things
that I've found that they changed from
the books but feel free to add stuff
first off they didn't do the phone
number in the book instead hazel just
waits for Augustus to call then they
didn't do the V for Vendetta scene where
ever she puts her hand out and he
doesn't try to hold it they did the you
know should I go in for a kiss double
take
next up Caitlin and hazel did not go
shopping been hazel never ended up
peeping on Augustus his ex-girlfriend
hazel never ended up breeding Van
Houten's letter in the hospital they
don't write the funny swingset
advertisements lonely vaguely pedophilic
swingset seeks butts of children hazel
and isaac never played video games
together
Augustus never ended up fighting with
his family before they went to Amsterdam
when they were on that boat tour of
Amsterdam people don't yell out how
beautiful they are
they didn't drink champagne on the
flight Augustus and Hazel --zz families
never ended up getting together for
dinner
we didn't meet Augustus his extended
family and hazel never got upset with
all the condolences from people after a
gust died
oh and one more instead of divergent
being on Hazel's shelf they had Hunger
Games just because she and Luke Woodley
said in real life
thought it would be too weird and take
people out of the movie so like I said
even if you don't consider yourself part
of nerdfighteria dftba and go see this
movie then let me know what you think my
next movie review is gonna be for How to
Train Your Dragon 2 so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'm also working
on a special Doctor Who video for
tomorrow I'm getting ready to cross
250,000 subscribers and I'm gonna try
and post it right as I cross the line so
that's all going down tomorrow on
Saturday right now click here to learn
about Emily Blunt maybe becoming the new
Catwoman or miss Marvel and click here
to learn why I think Benedict
Cumberbatch needs to become Doctor
Strange thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
okay okay